SHIMON PROKUPECZ TRACKED HIM
DOWN AND CONFRONTED HIM OVER HIS
PRIVATE REASSURANCE TO HIS
OFFICERS.
>> PEOPLE HAVE ACCUSED YOU OF
BEING PART OF A COVER-UP.
>> THAT'S CORRECT.
THAT'S FINE.
>> DO YOU DISAGREE WITH THAT?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> IT'S BEEN THREE AND A HALF
MONTH SINCE THE UVALDE MASSACRE,
SINCE THE FAILED POLICE RESPONSE
THAT LEFT A GUNMAN ALONE IN A
CLASSROOM FULL OF CHILDREN AND
THEIR TEACHERS FOR OVER AN HOUR.
IN THAT TIME, ANGER AT THE TEXAS
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC SAFETY HAS
ONLY GROWN.
THE AGENCY HAD 91 OFFICERS WHO
RESPONDED.
NONE HAS LOST THEIR JOB OR FACED
ANY CONSEQUENCES.
DPS OFFICIALS NEVER FULLY
ANSWERED ANY OF THE LINGERING
QUESTIONS ABOUT ITS OFFICERS'
ACTIONS THAT DAY.
NOT TO FURIOUS PARENTS, TO AN
ANGRY TOWN MAYOR, OR TO ANY
REPORTERS UNTIL NOW.
FIRST OF ALL, THERE'S NO
COVER-UP.
AND THE BOTTOM LINE IS AS SOON
AS WE CAN, WE'LL RELEASE
EVERYTHING.
>> IT NEEDS TO BE DONE.
THE FAMILIES ARE STARVING FOR
INFORMATION.
>> IT WILL BE DONE WHEN THE
DISTRICT ATTORNEY SAYS SO.
>> THIS WEEK, TWO OFFICERS WERE
SUSPENDED WITH PAY AND REFERRED
FOR INFORMAL INVESTIGATION BY
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL.
THE DEPARTMENT SAYS THREE OTHERS
WILL ALSO BE INVESTIGATED.
CNN TRACKED DOWN DPS DIRECTOR
STEVEN McCRAW AFTER OBTAINING
MINUTES FROM AN INTERNAL MEETING
HELD IN AUGUST.
THESE MINUTES SEEM TO PAINT A
VERY DIFFERENT PICTURE THAN THE
PLEDGE OF FULL ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT DPS CHIEF HAS GIVEN
PUBLICLY.
AND OH, BY THE WAY, THE MINUTES
QUOTE HIM, NO ONE IS LOSING
THEIR JOBS.
QUITE THE CONTRARY, ALL LEADERS
IN REGION THREE DID WHAT THEY
WERE SUPPOSED TO DO AND HAVE
STEPPED UP TO MEET THE MOMENT.
>> YOU SAID NO ONE IS LOSING
THEIR JOBS.
>> I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
>> YOU'RE DENYING YOU SAID THAT?
>> I'M DENYING I SAID THAT.
>> YOU'RE DENYING YOU SAID NO
ONE IS GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOB.
VICTOR ESCOLON IS THE DPS
REGIONAL DIRECTOR FOR SOUTH
TEXAS.
HE CAN BE SEEN IN THE HALLWAY AT
ROBB ELEMENTARY AND IN THE DAYS
AFTER HE REPEATEDLY HELPED
DELIVER INCORRECT INFORMATION TO
THE MEDIA.
BEFORE THIS, McCRAW HAS NOT
GIVEN ANY EXTENSIVE INTERVIEWS
SINCE THE MAY 24 ATROCITY.
HE BECAME A PUBLIC FACE OF THE
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE IN THE
DAYS AFTER.
FIRST, AT A TABLE WITH TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT, WHEN THE
EFFORTS OF OFFICERS WERE
PRAISED.
>> LAW ENFORCEMENT WAS THERE,
THEY DID ENGAGE IMMEDIATELY.
>> THEN, AT A LATER NEWS
CONFERENCE WHEN HE ADMITTED TO
THE POLICE FAILURE.
>> FOR THE BENEFIT OF HINDSIGHT,
WHERE I'M SITTING NOW, OF
COURSE, IT WAS NOT THE RIGHT
DECISION.
>> AND IN TEXAS SENATE TESTIMONY
WHEN HE CALLED THE OPERATION A,
QUOTE, ABJECT FAILURE.
>> I DON'T CARE IF YOU HAVE
FLIP-FLOPS AND ARE WEARING
BERMUDA SHORTS.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
YOU GO IN.
>> McCRAW'S COMMENTS PUT HIM IN
THE MIDDLE OF A VASTLY CHANGER
NARRATIVE THAT LEFT HIM AND HIS
DEPARTMENT OPEN TO CRITICISM BY
THE UVALDE MAYOR, THE VICTIMS'
FAMILIES, AND LOCAL POLITICIANS.
>> I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT.
>> I CAN'T THINK OF ANY MORE
IMPORTANT THING.
>> THAT'S WHY PEOPLE THINK
THERE'S A COVER-UP, BECAUSE NO
ONE IS TALKING ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED.
>> WHEN WE GET THE ABILITY TO
TALK, I'LL GO LINE BY LINE IN
TERMS OF WHAT TROOPER DID WHAT,
BUT NOT WHAT TROOPER, WHAT DP
SRS OFFICER.
WE'LL BE ENTIRELY TRANSPARENT.
THE PUBLIC WILL HAVE IT.
THEY'LL HAVE EXCRUCIATING
DETAILS IN TERMS OF WHAT WE DID,
WHEN WE DID IT, AND THOSE GAPS,
AND LIKE I SAID, WHAT WE'RE NOT
GOING TO DO IS NOT GOING TO GIVE
ANYBODY AN OPPORTUNITY TO
UNDERMINE THE CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> NOW, McCRAW SAYS HE'LL RESIGN
IF HIS AGENCY WAS SHOWN TO HAVE
CULPABILITY FOR THE BOTCHED
RESPONSE.
>> I'LL BE THE FIRST TO RESIGN,
OKAY.
I'LL BE GLADLY RESIGNING, TENDER
MY RESIGNATION TO THE GOVERNOR
IF I THINK THERE